Diana is with us in De Mo Iowa hi Diana
how are you oh God is great thank you so
much for taking my call amen how can I
help today um well my when my son turned
14 which was about a year ago he wanted
a job he was very adamant um we kept
going around nobody would hire him cuz
he wasn't 16 yet and I asked him what
was his Rush of getting a job and he
hears my husband and I talking about
debt and he says you guys in debt and I
want to start helping I want to pay my
fair share and I was just in shock and I
um that was a week ago and I opened up
dve ramsey.com and I went online cuz I
just put autopay the minimum payment for
my credit cards and all my debt and I
couldn't believe how much debt I was in
and I mean I um the question is for him
what do I do for him I don't want him to
make the same mistakes I did did and am
doing well I shredded my credit cards
immediately um um and start a baby step
one and I want him to get a job but I
want to know he I don't want him to get
a job because he thinks you all are in
trouble and he has to help you no I
don't want him to get the job to help me
I want him to get the job well you need
first thing you need to do is correct
that this idea that the 16-year-old is
going to save the house okay no no we
don't owe anything on our house credit I
know but my point is if there's been
enough yaking around your house that
this kid's worried yes so you need to
take that worry off of him the only
reason he needs to get a job is for him
and that's what I tell him I go it's for
you but then he wants to know okay what
do I do should I save it all should I
pay you should always do four things
with money whether you're whether you're
three or whether you're 53 you should
work to earn it you should give you
should give some of it you should save
some of it you should enjoy spending
some of it give give save work and spend
give save work and spend give save work
and spin I've got a wonderful book that
I wrote with my daughter Rachel Cruz
it's called smart money smart kids to
how to teach your kids how to handle
money from a parents perspective how to
teach your kids how to handle money I'll
send you a copy as my gift you will
enjoy it just make sure this young man's
not worried that he has to carry the
weight of the household that's unfair
for a 16-year-old and it's not accurate
either this is the dayve Ramsey
Show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the Subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the
[Music]
[Applause]
show